hey what's up my name's samuel leeds hey
officer leeds
and we are going to be discussing the
help to buy scheme
and how it has screwed over a lot of
buyers and first-time buyers i'm frankly
really upset about it about what's
happening
russell on the other hand doesn't agree
with me and russell thinks that the help
to buy scheme is a great
scheme that helps people out i actually
think you're
joking i can't believe you're even
serious in saying that absolute
nonsense um okay
you want me to back it up now exactly
believe that the help to buy scheme
helps buyers and is a nice good scheme
i'm in the health bar scheme um listen i
think it's an amazing scheme i'm not
saying the help to buy scheme is
brilliant
what it is what it is is this a sham
um come on
explain why it's a sham okay and then
i'll tell you why you're wrong okay
you know what they say they say uh
audacity doesn't cost anything
and listen the help to buy scheme as you
know as a developer is actually help to
sell
it's not help to buy it's very very much
helped to sell i agree with that yeah
so calling it help to buy scheme is
misleading
because you can't quite help they
couldn't call it help to sell scheme
could that they couldn't say this is the
because it's got to appeal to to the to
the bias
all of the schemes from there as well
all of the schemes
yeah all of these schemes um even
student loans
whether what the government want you to
do is they want you to go to university
be a good boy good girl
they want you to get a a degree they
want you then save up money put it in
the bank
they want you to then buy your first
home they want you to buy a
stupid overpriced new build home from a
rich developer
they want the rich to get richer and the
poor to get poorer they want you to look
forward to your
pension and die broke
that's the system and it annoys me when
i see people
falling for it and i think as working
class people ourselves we grew up with
very little
i think that i can't believe that you as
someone that benefits from the help to
buy a scheme as a developer
as someone that benefits you're you're
the rich person hiding away
you're the rich person you're the rich
person that that's saying oh no i think
it's great and
if i'm honest bro i honestly believe the
reason you think it's great is because
you
financially benefit from it and you've
seen my youtube videos you've seen what
my youtube videos are about
we are of the same heart we run a
training company together
but it just shocked me when i heard you
say when and it was a result of this
article which i'm going to read in a
minute all right cool right here's the
thing right and
the government have got their own agenda
yeah so whatever whatever it might be so
for example they've got an agenda that
they want
us to drive electric cars yeah so as a
result they make it very beneficial
for tax reasons et cetera et cetera for
you to drive an electric car
they've got an agenda that they want you
to do that
you know like uh robert kiyosaki says
doesn't he they don't want you to pay
those attacks
they actually they set it up so that if
you do what they want you get tax breaks
yeah so that's why the rich get richer
and the poor get poorer because the
the taxes are for the poor and middle
class yeah
yeah i agree yeah right so whatever
their agenda is in this case
i think they've got an agenda with the
help to buy a scheme of
they want more homes in the uk yeah so
they've thought imagine you were the
government now and you're thinking okay
i want more more home more houses built
in the uk
how do i do that well the first thing i
need to do is i need to get developers
to build more houses
so i'm going to create a scheme that
just ticks two boxes right the first
thing that it takes
is it makes it um financially viable
for developers to build more houses and
be able to sell them and get a good
profit
because you know you know like a lot of
deals that you fight it's sometimes hard
to find a deal
where you're going to make a lot of
profit out of it with house prices and
et cetera if you're
finding land sometimes you can find very
profitable deals but often you'll find a
plot of land it's like oh that doesn't
stack up
right it's not viable so they want more
houses
they need to make it stack up so they've
come up with a really
good scheme i think that does two things
number one it makes it very beneficial
for developers but number two it allows
people
who otherwise wouldn't be able to get on
the housing ladder
it allows them to pay a five percent um
deposit now i'm not saying it's the best
scheme in the world but when you compare
it to
not buying anything and just renting and
then
you were saying yeah i've got friend
people i went to school with
um who have used the hell to buy a
scheme and if it wasn't for that they'd
be renting so
i don't think it's a bad deal for them
it's not brilliant it's not ideal
uh i don't think it's the an amazing
scheme yeah but i don't think it's i
don't think it's the devil like you seem
to think it is i think that's more where
i'm coming from
i understand that here's my massive
problem with it don't understand what
you're saying
my massive problem with it is that
they're trying as you just said
to help developers yeah build more homes
make more money but instead of instead
of saying that instead of maybe giving
the developers a tax break
or instead of maybe putting some money
towards their build costs or whatever or
helping the builders what they're doing
is they're they're taking the money from
the poor people
well they're not taking money from them
but what they're doing is they're
relying on them their ignorance
so they're taking people that don't know
what they're doing and they're saying
hey
we'll give you some money we'll help you
by yourself
but what's the alternative the
alternative is what would they do if it
wasn't for the government
what would happen let's say the help to
buy scheme didn't exist what do you
think these people that use it would do
instead i don't know
but what i do know is that they are
often uneducated people
and they don't know much about
investments and they're told we're gonna
help you buy a house
but then they're told oh but you've got
to live in the house you can't rent it
out it has to be a new build
and when you buy a new build house it
drops in value straight away
so now they're in a lot of them with
negative effects it's these types of
articles
bro that just that just freaked me out
and i just feel so bad for them let me
let me read this okay this was literally
published
uh this month october the 8th uh by the
mirror and of course you can't read the
media you can't listen to the media so
we're gonna have to make our
our own conclusions after reading the
media first time buyers discover their
three bed new build property is worth
absolutely nothing
chris and steph oliver bought their home
for 130 000 pounds in 2014
with a 20 help to buy loan however last
year
they discovered huge unfinished problems
with the development
new build homes have come under the
spotlight in recent years
with developers accused of cutting
corners and inflating prices to cash in
on those using the help to buy scheme so
again there's so many people that again
that are getting suckered in by this and
the
and the government you might say well
that's the developers that's not the
government but the government are
enabling them
you haven't explained why the house is
now worth nothing so carry on okay
we've heard from the buyers who've been
left trapped in unsellable homes
whilst others say they're locked in
punishing leasehold clauses
oh that is bad that's terrible yeah the
lease that's not the help to buy scheme
what's happening is developers are
flogging their
crappy houses their shiny crappy houses
onto poor first-time buyers and the
government are going yeah we'll help you
that house ticks the box
95 of houses don't ticks the box but
that has ticks the box they'll be like
me having my kids
right and the thing is the people look
to the government as like a parent
yeah do they though the government is a
parent i don't think so
people people look to the government for
benefits for help for support
they get they get student loans backed
by the government
they they go into the people taking
advantage of the government when they
can no people rely on the government
yeah of course
of course they i'm not saying they don't
really like what i'm saying on my videos
and on my channel as i'm saying hey
don't rely on the government think and
look at what they're doing and you see
that these schemes
are not to help you despite having the
words
help to buy for help the buyers it's not
to help the buyers
what to turn your phone on silent bro i
mean just just when i couldn't be more
irritated with you right now
your phone's pinging right so it's like
it's knocked out so so
so this these people okay these people
are buying houses and now they're worth
nothing
and they were backed by the government
not now yeah
but but why is it worth nothing you
haven't said why it's worth nothing no
it's worth nothing there's many cases so
in this case
one of the main issues so one of the
main is probably loads
is that the aesthetic backs onto a
former landfill site
okay so this isn't anything to do with
methane gas
this is to do with the the the it
shouldn't have been soldered
that they use the hell that's like
saying oh it's a mortgage company they
use the wrong mortgage basically what
you're saying
new builds always drop in value straight
when you buy a new boat it's like
buying a car when you drive it off it
drops okay well let's talk about that
let's talk about this example it's got
nothing to do with that dubai scheme
it's about the landfill
this is obviously an extreme example
yeah that's a different thing that
i that's terrible what's your point okay
my point is that is obviously terrible
yeah nobody should have helped to buy
that that's to do with
whoever stopped the mortgage company or
whoever signed that off
because help to buy is only for brand
new builds what are you saying that we
shouldn't be able to buy
new build houses i'm saying to encourage
somebody to buy a brand new house listen
no no no no let's listen a sec to
encourage someone to buy a brand new
house
to live in is stupid
it's not if it is maybe for that person
if they're they're well it depends on
what they want what they want right
if it's either that or renting and not
buying what would you what would you
rather here's a question for you
what do you think's better so let's say
let's say um
chels for example yeah would it be
better for her help to buy so she owns
yeah or renting i'd i'd rent
and not buying anything yeah i'd rent
because she's still gonna put five
percent a little bit of money yeah it's
like what five
i was great i never get trapped into a
house where i've got a load of mortgage
debt and debt to the government
buying a new build housing in the long
run though in the long run you'd look
back and you'd go oh i'm actually glad i
did that rather than
i'm glad i tell you when i wouldn't be
at the five grand i wouldn't if you look
at all the
millions of people that have bought
using help to buy schemes apartments
i'll show you another article i'll show
you another article um yeah but all
these articles got loads of help to buy
they're all like they have everything to
do with help to buy all right look at
this
um this is uh help to buy with cladded
apartments with nothing
or grandfather graham the people that
bought
grenville and died with the fire which
were
council owned apartments
were terrible apartments had
cladding that was highly flammable which
was a dreadful story
okay but the people that died or the
people that
lived in those apartments bought those
apartments
with help to buy skiing so what they do
is they sell their
crap properties off to suckers
vulnerable people
that that are like oh go on then and
then they sell their crap
and then people end up being stuck in
debt i think you're confusing
crap new builds with the help department
no i'm saying
they help to buy these properties that
people have helped to buy schemes are
often
terrible investments in fact they're not
even investments they're that they're
liabilities that people are having to
live in it's almost like the government
just want people to be so
broke and so trapped you know in student
debt
then in debt buying new builds to live
in what what about educating people to
actually be financially literate
and make good investment decisions
rather than saying we're helping you
is the thing right do you think
it's a good thing having more homes in
the uk
well people need homes in the uk yes so
do you think it's a good thing to have
new homes in the uk
um yeah because it's needed okay right
so
what's your issue here then is it with
my issue is the the way that they
market this to help to buy so your issue
isn't to do with the scheme is to do
with the marketing of the scheme
my issue is to do with the way that they
actually help it's actually helping the
economy isn't it
it's actually helping to help in the
housing market it's not helping it's not
helping
um young families that are struggling to
make ends meet that are getting stuck in
these help
no it's not helping them at all well
it's helping them over just rent it
it goes back to the very beginning of
this conversation you're looking at this
very much from your point of view
as a developer from the economy i'm
looking at it from the people that i
speak to day in day out
that are getting brainwashed by the
government that getting sucked into this
complete nonsense that that's all i'm
thinking for
i see what you're saying i see what
you're saying and like
but i actually here's a question here's
a question then would you
okay would you ever under any
circumstances
go into the help to buy scheme me
personally yes well you know of course i
wouldn't i haven't
have i so so you'd never would you
encourage your kids
no i wouldn't know so
yeah but because i know a better way
what i'm saying is it's not the worst
way
so like obviously i would encourage them
to invest and to rent where they live
like what i do i think that's the best
way i don't think the health department
so you would never do it you would never
encourage your kids to do it but the
government are going out there flogging
it like it's the best thing since sliced
bread with their own agenda
with actually you know the government of
everything so the thing is right is what
you need to do
is look at their schemes and go okay
they're not doing this for me
i don't see the government as my parents
they're doing it for them right
and i'm just gonna have a little look at
them and see ah that one fits the best i
agree with that
i agree with that but most people most
people most people don't do that
most people see the headlines they have
no idea they don't even understand the
difference between good debt and bad
debt do you think it's wrong
that they've got of course they're gonna
have their own agenda
of course they are because they're also
you know it's not like they're just
they want there's this massive what's
their agenda they're not teaching money
in schools
what's their agenda then of encouraging
people to go to university
someone said to me the other day is
there any government grants for your
property investors academy i was like no
of course there's not because the last
thing the government want you doing
is coming on my academy it doesn't fit
with their agenda their agenda is for
you to get into student debt
buy a house to live in have a job
have a pension dangle the carrot to
retire early
and that i have a problem you know what
is it interesting though i actually
let's say for example that that all
changed
and suddenly everyone was was was going
on the your academy and
and everyone what would actually be
obviously individual people benefit from
that what would actually be the long
term effects of that brilliant things
amazing things go on what would it be i
don't know i don't know the answer okay
what i do and what you do yeah is we i
train
people to be an entrepreneur okay the
definition of an entrepreneur
is someone that solved people's problems
for profit
the more people the more entrepreneurs
there are on the planet
the more people everyone was an
entrepreneur what would be amazing it'd
be amazing
who would you get to work for you well
are you saying that are you saying that
you can't be entrepreneurial work for
somebody most millionaires are employees
no i'm not saying we like entrepreneurs
in our company
entrepreneurs yeah so what i'm saying is
when you leave school
okay and we could go off on a whole
nother thing now and i want to wrap this
up in a minute but when you leave school
at the moment it's either you go to
university and you get a normal
education and get
a degree back by the government great or
you go to college and then a trade you
use your hands you
are practical you become an apprentice
they're the two options and they're the
only two options people think
and what i'm trying to do what we're
trying to do is encourage people that
there's a third option there is a third
much better one the third option is to
be an entrepreneur and not to be scoffed
at
laughed at ridiculed you know how badly
i was ridiculed when i started
when i was 17 and i said i'm going to be
i'm going to go on first it's not the
normal it's not the wrong way
to become a normal a lot of people
though i don't think that they would
they won't want that route they want to
go and
and they don't want to do that if they
want to go and get into bad debt
and get into go get get a degree in
geography
and then get a career and retire at 67
years old on after working 40 hours a
week for 40 years
because they're not driven they just
want a job
but the problem i have the problem i
have is that the government mislead
people into they think that they're
being helped when actually there's a
much bigger agenda
but what they probably should do okay
maybe right but i think everyone knows
the government got their own agenda
i don't think they do i think people
trust the government
if you ask them do they trust the
government though it's the same as when
people say i don't trust politicians but
they all listen to boris's speech and
take it as gospel and people say they
don't trust the media but they do
the media bashed me and everyone thinks
it must be true because the media said
it but you ask people and they'll say no
i don't trust the government i know i
don't trust the media no i don't trust
the politicians they actually
in practice they do and the government
are putting out messages that are
completely misleading
if i put messages out like the
government put out i would be done by
trading standards for misleading
advertising would i not
oh yeah so they're doing things that are
so misleading that businesses can't do
it but they get away with i think it's
wrong
but you but you but you should be able
to what you should be able to make up
your own mind
but yeah but what i'm saying is people
are being misled
misled people are being shown one half
of the picture yes
and my job on youtube on the other half
it's a show the other half yeah i agree
with that make up your own mind at least
at least at least at least look at the
fact but i don't it's not like that it's
not like the help to buy
scheme is like an absolute con
it's it's it's serving a purpose what it
is it's fitting what it is
is it's an absolute con it's exactly
what it is
guys we're gonna wrap up it was an
interesting one
i'm beginning to dislike russell more
and more by the day maybe you agree with
russell maybe you agree with me maybe
you have your own opinion what i want
though is i want to see what you think
comment below in the comment box if you
want to see another video a bit like
this me must having another argument
you beat me at the last argument i think
i might have had the edge on this one
i don't think we're a million miles away
what we think if you want to see me
invest having another argument check it
out up here
right there that's amazing also if you
want to see my students that are winning
because they didn't believe the nonsense
of the government and russell speak
then check out a whole list of them up
here right here and don't forget to
subscribe to my channel but not
russell's he doesn't even have a channel
my channel subscription is right here
subscribe i'll see you next time i don't
agree with the government i'm just
saying
it's not terrible